every movie that I've seen every movie
that it's had a profound effect on me it
has made me who I am hi my name is Bob
Harper and my favorite movie is ordinary
people
it affected me in a way that no movie
had ever affected me before I was
devastated I felt like I was part of
this family I've always been gravitated
toward movies that focus on analysis
feelings are scary sometimes the painful
I feel like Judd Hirsch in that movie
all the time you can't feel pain and
you're not gonna feel anything else
either but I also can relate to Donald
Sutherland just mean the man that just
wants you know everyone to get along and
everyone to love each other the buck
died It was as if you buried all your
love with him and I don't understand
that I just don't know I know but then I
can relate to Mary Tyler Moore I
understand I understand her being so
shut down it makes sense to me that I
would love a movie like ordinary people
because of that analysis part because
that's what I have to do in my job every
single day it's like they're giving
themselves to me and I'm having to look
at all the players involved with in the
cast tell me about your mother tell me
about your father tell me what your
childhood was like and then start
piecing everything together because a
lot of times people just aren't aware
the profound effect your childhood has
on who you are as an adult I like to see
life for what it really is and life is
tough life is beautiful life has
challenges
ordinary people really put one family in
front of you and you were sitting there
psychoanalyzing like that I can relate
to so many people in this movie because
I think I look I there's bits of me and
every one of those characters that's
such a truthful moment oh my god I gotta
get out of here my name is Bob Harper
and I love movies that's a wrap